voilà c'est la semaine de la forme c'est
aussi la semaine de la mode cet essai
c'est cette semaine en effet à paris et
jusqu'à mercredi prochain les
spécialistes de la mode les créateurs
par exemple se rassemblent et font
défiler leurs modèles dans des endroits
tout à fait insolite parfois c'est aussi
bien à l'école de médecine côte
huileries alors nous nous avons voulu
pour vous présenter cette mode en parler
des endroits un petit peu différent
alors ce n'est pas chez vous chers
france roche
ce n'est pas chez moi non plus nous
sommes un petit intérieur c'est bien sûr
le décor de télématin que nous ont
prêtés nos amis de télématin william
leymergie patrick lecocq christian mary
mono alors france on parle c'est vrai de
plus en plus de la mode en ce moment et
elle et j'ai l'impression de plus en
plus extravagantes extravagantes
peut-être pas mais en tout cas elle elle
s'implante de plus en plus dans les
moeurs par exemple hier et bien la mode
a pénétré dans la bibliothèque nationale
voyez il y à un passage dans paris il
s'appelle la galerie vivienne même le
passage colbert qui a été acheté en
partie par la bibliothèque nationale est
en partie il y aura une galerie
marchande ou notamment le couturier jean
paul gaultier aura son magasin à leur
architecture étonnante mosaïque parterre
poste de télévision sous le sol où on
voit la télévision sous ses pieds chose
de métal dans jean de la tour eiffel et
à l'arrière
il ya eu la grande fête de la mode je
dirais que c'était la foire qu'on
pourrait appeler t'as le look coco
alors on va voir un petit peu se
reportant leur souci a été tourné par
dan stahl au riz avait des gens comme
cet homme sur des échasses denim ou des
prestidigitateurs
mais il le fait à peine plus étrange que
les journalistes de mode du monde entier
qui étaient venus voir ce spectacle
d'abord c'était la grande ferme une
amende puisqu'on se promenait sur un
manège de chevaux bois avec des petits
cochons
et nous avons pu remarquer avec dan que
les hommes portaient beaucoup la jupe
alors pour les hommes généralement c'est
la jupe longue
vous allez voir d'abord jolie coiffure
vous voyez de santé jean pierre gross
jean paul gaultier qui avait lui une
jupe courte
là c'est un prestidigitateur
et vous allez voir nous messieurs avec
leurs jupes longues et alors c'était
très colorés vous voyez là il ya
vraiment on vient vraiment un effort ou
alors c'est tout noir et blanc même les
lèvres en noir et la figure très blanc
rayé ce monsieur là très abstrait en
dire un combat alors des petits foulards
noués comme ça sur la tête alors trois
jupes l'ont porté par des messieurs jupe
courte portée par une dame et au plus la
très très chic sa jupe est faite dans
une couverture dans son coeur koweïtien
boucles d'oreilles naturellement pour
messieurs recherche de couleurs aussi
fond des dames en raison qu'est ce qu'on
en reste
et alors voilà le fameux la fameuse
télévision sous les pieds en viande à la
beauté société alors là nous allons
devoir nous alors nous d'abord françois
de questions j'ai pas du tout look
comment ça va pas du tout comment ils
commandent et il y avait quand même
janvier avec notre question c'était tout
on a vu la mode